[Musique]
bonjour je suis vraiment ravi d'être
avec vous cet après midi pour partager
ce qui me passionne
ce qui me fait vibrer et ce qui
m'inspire tous les jours et qui à mes
yeux caractérise excellemment les liens
entre l'individuel et le collectif
cette salle dont je vais vous parler en
fait j'adore le basket ball
j'adore ce sport c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je trouve incroyable et ce que
je veux partager avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est que j'ai pu vivre de telles
émotions de fraternité de partage de
solidarité dans ce sport des choses
vraiment incroyables
bon et puis des fois quand même la
déception la frustration qui parfois de
l'injustice c'est vrai bon le basket
c'est top
pour autant c'est vrai que j'ai quand
même connu des émotions encore plus
forte
par exemple le jour où je me suis marié
avec mon épouse quand même ça a pris pas
et puis après ça il ya eu la naissance
de mes magnifiques enfants clément et
margot des émotions pour le coup
incomparable mais après ces deux
événements là je dois reconnaître que
c'est vraiment le basket qui m'a permis
d'être le plus touché le plus inspiré
pour le coup le plus connecté avec les
autres et je pense que ça s'explique par
la notion de partage
la notion de solidarité le fait d'être
ensemble pour vivre ces éléments-là bon
vous les avez vu les basketteurs des
fois c'est arrivé il y en a avec des
tatouages dans tous les sens
des cheveux comme ça des bandeaux des
boisnier plongeon c'est pas pourquoi il
y en a qui ont des ornements incroyable
le paradoxe en même temps c'est que ils
ont tous la même tenue une tenue qu'on
appelle un uniforme d'ailleurs uniforme
ça veut dire une seule forme à quoi ça
sert en fait si je joue avec les verts
c'est quand même mieux que je vois que
mon pote là bas il est en verre pour
pouvoir lui faire la passe pour gagner
des matches c'est mieux ça sert à ça
qu'on ait la même tenue et alors à quoi
ça sert ses tatouages qui est ce qu'ils
veulent nous dire les basketteurs ce
qu'ils veulent nous dire c'est ok
je fais partie de cette équipe je fais
partie de ce groupe je suis dans ce
collectif
mais pour autant moi je suis quelqu'un
de différent
je veux que vous leur père y est bien je
suis quelqu'un de différent et je pense
pas qu'on doive les juges et qu'on aime
d'ailleurs les tatouages ou pas ce n'est
pas le sujet je pense pas qu'on doive
laissus les jugé là dessus parce que là
je vous vois pas trop bien avec les
lumières mais il me semble pas qu'il y
en ait deux d'entre vous qui soit venu
pile avec la même tenue
et en fait on fait tout ça chaque jour
tous autant qu on est est ce que vous
connaissez la règle des 3 jamais
vous la connaissez pas la règle des 3
jamais ça tombe bien on va en parler
alors la règle des 3 jamais ce quelque
chose de vraiment important parce que
c'est ce qui permet de différencier les
grandes équipes sportives des moins
bonnes
et en fait c'est ce qui peut permettre à
des équipes sportives constituée de
joueurs moins talentueux de battre celle
avec les soi-disant joueurs plus
talentueux de dans ces équipes là le
fonctionnent avec des principes tout
simple qui vont consister à essayer de
mettre en place cette règle des 3 jamais
qui signifie qu'il s'agit de ne jamais
critiquer ne jamais se plaindre et ne
jamais condamné moi ça m'est déjà arrivé
quand je jouais effectivement ça m'est
déjà arrivé de critiquer un peu le
meneur de jeu là sur la fin de contrat
taki filer la balle à l'autre et je
n'étais pas content et cetera sauf que
quand je faisais ça je n'ai pas la
performance de mon équipe
et puis il ya un autre truc qui est
hyper important et qui va avec ces
règles là c'est quelque chose qu'on
appelle l'attribution cause à l'externe
alors peu importe les mots je dois
reconnaître que quand je jouais
j'étais pas forcément si tendres que ça
avec les arbitres et qui m'est déjà
arrivé à la fin d'un match perdu de peu
de dire ouais bah on a perdu c'est la
faute de l'arbitré voulait déjà entendu
ça on l'a tous entendu et c'est
tellement facile
l'attribution cause à l'externe ça veut
dire j'attribue la cause de ce qui s'est
passé et potentiellement de ce qui s'est
mal passé aux autres donc pendant ce
temps là c'est tranquille je me
déresponsabilise et j'imagine que les
autres sont responsables de mes heures
de mes échecs et c est ce que je veux
partager avec vous c'est que les plus
grands champions sportifs lorsqu'ils
arrivent à se départir de ses trois
jamais de l'attribution causal de ces
choses là
et lorsqu'ils arrivent à prendre leur
part de responsabilité au final ils sont
plus efficaces d'une part plus
performants mais aussi plus connectés
entre eux parce que ça ça compte aussi
et puis encore autre chose c'est ça je
me suis rendu compte que moi quand je
joue et ça ça me le faisait souvent et
ça m'aidait pas être bon et que dans
notre vie de tous les jours on le met en
place il ya une civilisation hyper
ancien qui fonctionnait bien qu'ils
fonctionnaient de façon hyper amende
harmonieuse c'était la civilisation tout
et qu'ils ont vécu en gros il ya mille
ans de ça c'est pas ça le plus important
plus important de ça c'est qu'ils
fonctionnaient selon des accords qui
leur permettait de bien vivre ensemble
et c'est ça que je partage avec vous et
oyonnax tombe notamment un qui était
très important qui était celui là qui
consiste à ne pas faire de supposition
en gros ça m'est déjà arrivé je jouais
le coach décidé de ne pas me faire jouer
à tel moment et j'étais en train de me
dire bon ça veut dire quoi qu'est-ce qui
peut penser sur moi qui l ai si on idée
qu'elle et son intention et caetera et
caetera et pendant ce temps là mais on
n'est pas centré sur ce qu'on doit faire
dans l'ici et maintenant dans l'action
et dans l'efficacité et plus comme les
plus grands sportifs plus nous dans
notre vie de tous les jours on essaye de
ne pas faire des procès d'intention aux
autres ça peut être ça peut être pour
vous vous croisez un collègue de bureau
dans un couloir
il marche très vite ils vous croiser il
vous dit même pas bonjour à j'en étais
sûr iman veut le pionnier des fois c'est
juste qu'il est concentré sur ce qu'il a
à faire et qui nous a quasi pas vu et on
se fait des suppositions et des films et
plus on arrive encore une fois à bannir
ça et à s'en départir
plus on sera efficace alors je vous la
corde
tout ça c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile du tout et du coup ça me fait
penser à une vraie anecdote une vraie
situation qui a eu lieu lors d'un temps
mort d'un match de play-offs des san
antonio spurs en nba
la nba le championnat américain les san
antonio spurs nous autres les français
on connaît plutôt puisque c'est l'équipe
dans laquelle tony parker joue et en
fait il se trouve que 1 des matches de
play-off il ya un des joueurs qui
arrivent qui s'affale sur le banc et qui
dit au coach le coach c'est cet homme
jovial que vous voyez sur l'écran
derrière
et lui fait coach c'est pas facile alors
qu'est-ce que gregg popovich lui a
répondu à ça ce qui lui a répondu cm1
on n'a jamais dit que ça serait facile
c'est pas moi j'ai l'impression aussi
que pour gagner un titre de nba c'est
pas un truc qui d'emblée comme ça est
facile et donc il leur rappelle que 1
on n'a jamais dit que ça serait facile
ensuite il ajoute deux ça sera de plus
en plus difficile c'est pas ça qui nous
intéresse le plus aujourd'hui mais en
play-offs jeu bat une équipe qui en a
battu une autre donc je joue contre une
plus forte
consécutivement un peu comme le tableau
final de roland garros et le 3 est
important
gregg popovich il a ensuite asséné à son
joueur et 3 c'est parce que c'est
difficile que ça a de la valeur c'est
parce que c'est difficile que ça a de la
valeur alors vous je sais pas comment ça
se passe dans votre vie moi ce que je
sais c'est que dans la mienne je n'ai
jamais obtenu quoi que ce soit qui ait
de valeur facilement les grand challenge
les grands objectifs dans nos vies ou en
tout cas dans la mienne on les obtient
parce que justement il faut transcender
des étapes faire face à des obstacles
etc etc
est ce que je voudrais vous inviter à
réfléchir c'est à chaque fois que dans
notre vie on est tenté parce que ça nous
vient rapidement à la bouche
ouais mais c'est pas facile à chaque
fois qu'on sent que ça va venir il
faudrait essayer de le rejeter pour la
simple et bonne raison que si je dis
c'est pas facile
c'est un premier pas pour ensuite aller
vers donc je lâche la faire et je laisse
tomber
et donc ça nous empêche de pouvoir
réaliser tout ce qu'on pourrait espérer
faire avec notre potentiel
et puis il ya autre chose qui n'est pas
facile en fait quand on passe beaucoup
de temps avec les gens on regarde plus
spontanément ce qui est sûrs ti quant à
nos yeux chez eux leurs défauts les
trucs qui nous agacent ce qui nous
énerve un peu parfois dans les maisons
dans les coupes c'est la paire de
chaussettes qui traîne la cuvette des
toilettes qui est pas relevé ça peut
être ce genre de choses insignifiantes
et on regarde plus ça et je voudrais
vous proposer une autre approche
je vous invite à fermer les yeux allez-y
fermé les yeux ce que je vous propose de
faire c'est de penser à une personne
avec qui vous passez beaucoup de temps
quelqu'un avec qui vous vivez ou
quelqu'un avec qui vous passez beaucoup
de temps
c'est bon vous l'avez que je vous
propose est ce que je vous invite à
faire c'est à réfléchir à une belle
qualité de cette personne magnifique
qualité qu'à sept personnes
bon vous pouvez revenir vous pouvez
revenir dans les équipes de sports
collectifs performante tout comme dans
notre vie tous les jours ce qui va nous
aider à mieux vivre ensemble et à mieux
performer
c'est véritablement l'idée d'accorder
beaucoup plus d'importance à ce qui nous
rapproche que ce qui nous sépare et
d'essayer davantage de regarder ses
qualités plutôt que ses défauts on en a
tous et plus j'arrive à regarder
davantage qui nous rapprocher davantage
les qualités de l'autre
plus on grandira ensemble les
basketteurs son grand ok c'est une belle
image
alors tout ça c'est simple certes c'est
pas facile j'en conviens est ce que je
voulais partager avec vous aussi c'est
une autre idée d'un auteur s'appelle
stephen covey et qui considère que pour
lui la priorité des priorités dans la
vie
ces quatre verbes d'action pour lui pour
stephen covey il s'agit de vivre aimer
apprendre et transmettre alors vivre je
pourrais vous parler je le fais
d'ailleurs de boris diaw capitaine
légendaire de l'équipe de france de
basket jovial rieurs bon vivant
quelqu'un qui est vraiment dans le fait
de vouloir partager
pour ce qui est des mais je pense
spontanément à tony parker boris diaw
encore et ronny turiaf ses joueurs qui
ont marqué l'équipe de france qui n'ont
d'ailleurs été tout champion nba avec
leur propre équipe et qu'ils ont décidé
tous les étés de sacrifier leurs
vacances pendant longtemps pour
simplement partager des moments ensemble
parce qu'ils s'aiment ils s'aiment de
fraternité mais ils s'aiment et c'est
une façon importante de faire ça et du
coup tous autant qu'on est on peut
s'inspirer d'eux pour essayer de voir
comment avec notre propre singularité on
peut définir nos priorités des priorités
alors comment le font-ils ronny turiaf 2
une armoire pas normande mais presque
des épaules comme ça des cheveux dans
tous les sens une grosse barbe quelqu'un
de très impressionnant comment est-ce
que ronnie lui il a mis en place ces
verbes là et ses intentions là ce qu'il
a fait et ronnie lui c'est qu'il arrive
était dans le don de soi
il a été connu en nba pour être un
energizer un energizer c'est celui qui
donne de l'énergie aux autres il a joué
avec les plus grands champions
kobe bryant lebron james qui adorait
jouer avec lui parce qu'il leur donnait
de l'énergie de l'abnégation du travail
de l'ombre qu'ils leur permettaient de
se magnifier c'est une façon de le faire
boris diaw jovial rieurs amoureux de la
vie et qui est caractérisée dans notre
sport par le fait d'être le plus
altruiste de tous les basketteurs boris
c'est l'homme qui adore ce geste en
basket qu'ont acquis et de faire une
passe et quand je fais une passe je te
transmet un masque est ce que j'ai de
plus précieux
tous ces coachs ce soit en nba ou en
france se sont arrachés les cheveux a
essayé de le rendre plus individualiste
ce qui est assez incroyable
fort heureusement aucun n'a réussi et
pour lui vivre aimer apprendre
transmettent c'était dans le dont
l'abnégation et l'altruisme et puis
évidemment tony parker la star du basket
français tony c'est incroyable on a
retrouvé des vidéos de lui il n'avait
pas dix ans il était en train de jouer
comme ça sur son petit terrain et il
disait quand je serai grand je jouerai
au san antonio spurs en nba
incroyable arrêtez t-il prophète je ne
sais pas par contre ça fait 17 ans qui
joue dans ce club et il bat tous les
records c'est quelque chose d'incroyable
et comment est ce que lui il vit ça il
apporte ça tony lui c'est le leadership
qu'il exprime alors le leadership
on n'a pas le temps de vous le balayer
tous que c'est simplement chez lui ça se
caractérise avec l'idée de prendre des
décisions
d'être présent dans les moments
difficiles quand il va falloir aller
marquer le dernier panier pour regarder
le match et que certains sont un peu
comme ça ils savent pas trop ce qu'il
faut faire on donne le ballon à tony
parker et lui il sait ce qu'il faudra
faire et c'est via cet acte qui peut
sembler individualisme et qui ne l'est
pas qui est l'aboutissement d'un
collectif que tony parker transmet tout
ce qu'il sait faire
et pour finir l'idée avec laquelle
j'aimerais qu'on puisse repartir c'est
quelque chose qui moi m'a marqué dans
une salle de basket dans un gymnase dans
lequel j'ai joué
allez on y va vous êtes mes coéquipières
mes coéquipiers on est sur le parquet on
y est tous et en fait figurez-vous que
là bas il ya une porte c'est la porte
qui mène au vestiaire et au dessus de
cette porte ce que l'on trouve c'est un
écriteau juste au dessus aussi important
que si on était sur le fronton du temple
de delphes à mes yeux il ya écrit la
chose suivante
as tu vraiment donner ton maximum did
you do your best as tu vraiment donner
ton maximum
alors en quoi cette phrase elle est
importante pour moi cette phrase elle
est essentielle parce que la dernière
année où je jouais dans ce club
j'avoue que je le savais que ce serait
ma dernière saison des fois le coach
regarder un peu plus les autres là moi
j'y allais est tranquille je paie n'est
pas trop et puis frais comme un gardon
pas mal aux jambes que j'allais par là
bas 1
as-tu vraiment donner ton maximum n'ont
pas vraiment ok bon bon message
d'humilité prochain coup il faudra y
revenir mais c'est valable dans l'autre
cas de figure une fois on joue en coupe
de france contre un grand club
le limoges csp le club le plus titré de
basket en france qui joue plusieurs
divisions au dessus de nous et puis on y
va on y va on y va dans tous les sens
sont des fonds si on y va et on perd
avec un sacré gros écarts et là c'est
l'inversé a battu les épaules rentrées
et puis finalement la tête se lève un
peu as tu vraiment donner ton maximum
ben ouais ouais ok donc si tu as donné
ton maximum bombe un peu le torse avant
ce que voulais tu faire et ce que je
vous propose c'est que dans notre vie à
nous comme les plus grands champions
sportifs le fond on essaye de s'inspirer
de cette phrase-là en essayant de se la
posait tout simplement as tu vraiment
donner ton maximum alors as-tu vraiment
donner ton maximum pour ce que tu as à
faire dans ta mission oui mais aussi
pour et par les autres as tu vraiment
donner ton maximum
merci
[Applaudissements]